[Music]  you are kendall roy you are [ __ ]  kendall roy is it true he's on his way  i don't see him yet with his stupid walk  no drama we're good i'm gonna [ __ ]  jump  the revolution will be televised  he's our dad but he was gonna send me to  jail he'd do the same to all of us  chev are you okay are you part of this  family or not  if i back you against death you would  need to let me take over  whoa nilly everyone's going to battle in  armor and i'm  sitting here exposed logan is going to  fire a million poisonous spiders down  your dickie  that that sounds like kind of dramatic  tom  ask yourself do you want to be on the  side of good for  people you tell them i'm gonna grind  these  [ __ ] bones to make my bread he says  he's going to grind your bones to make  his breath  okay tell him that i'm gonna run up off  the [ __ ]  [Music]  beanstalk  you